ينضم إلينا كثيرًا الآن بمنظور أكثر
، مدرب ديوكوفيتش السابق ولاعب
التنس المحترف السابق ،
أه وأسطورة التنس بوريس بيكر ، آه
، يسعدني أن أتحدث إليكم.
الأشخاص الآخرون ، ما هو
رد فعلك على الموقف ، في
المقام الأول ، أنا معجب كبير بك
وأشكرك كثيرًا على استضافتي في
البرنامج ، لا أم نوفاك مثل أحد أفراد عائلتي
بالنسبة لي وأنا كذلك  يكافح هذا أمر
مؤسف حقًا بالنسبة له ، فهو رجل جيد
ولديه اختلاف في الرأي مع
العديد من الأشياء لكنه شخصية جيدة جدًا
أه لم يكن ليأخذ
الطائرة إذا لم تكن أستراليا للتنس قد
أعطته الإعفاء الآن تنس
أستراليا  من الواضح أن لديه
سوء تفاهم مع الحكومة الأسترالية
وهذا هو سبب
احتجازها ولكن الأمر فظيع بالنسبة له
تخيل أنك تعلم أن هذا الرجل يأكل
نباتيًا لا يشرب مياهك العادية
ولا ينام في سرير عادي هو
ينظر  يعيش بطريقة مختلفة عن
معظم اللاعبين الآخرين ، ومن ثم فهو ناجح جدًا ،
لذا فإن وجوده
في غرفة كان موجودًا فيها خلال
اليومين الماضيين أمر فظيع